hay imágenes que de forma inmediata pasa
nada' historia esto es kabul en
afganistán el domingo 15 de agosto de
helicópteros estadounidenses trasladan
personal diplomático de la embajada al
aeropuerto ante la llegada del talibán
esto es saigón vietnam el 30 de abril de
1975 el último helicóptero
estadounidense recoge por una escalera a
evacuados en su embajada
paralelismos que desde eeuu se niegan a
aceptar el 8 de julio el presidente joe
biden decía que las imágenes de
evacuación de la embajada en saigón no
se iban a volver a ver algo que también
repitió el secretario de estado- anthony
blinken este domingo estamos un paso
atrás evidentemente esto no es algo la
guerra en afganistán ha durado 20 años
una amenaza que supuestamente había
terminado el 14 de abril cuando bardem
anunció el retiro de tropas
en afganistán debería estar justificada
en la razón por la que fuimos
asegurarnos de que afganistán no sería
utilizado como base desde la que
atacarían a nuestra patria de nuevo lo
hicimos
20 años duró la guerra de vietnam de los
cuales en más de 10 tuvo presencia
directa a eeuu el final llegó con el
anuncio de richard nixon
por el día por el que hemos trabajado y
rezado ha llegado por fin por primera
vez en 12 años no hay fuerzas americanas
en vietnam por todas las fuerzas armadas
están de camino al gas romero que envió
grandiosos hago me hueco
derrotas que se disfrazan de victoria
con un resultado de más de 150.000
muertos en afganistán y más de un millón
de dólares invertidos más de 3 millones
de muertos en vietnam y más de 680 mil
millones de dólares son los costes de
las dos intervenciones más largas en el
exterior